[Musique]
on sent libre ça y est c'est leur
partout au pays
les consommateurs de cannabis crient
victoire en seulement trois mois
les québécois ont acheté pour plus de 40
millions de cannabis à la escudé c'est à
la butte
[Musique]
mais la feuille de marque gervais de
saint jérôme a été plutôt éphémère
moi ma vie de tous les jours ce n'est
pas pour ce légal de ce week-end j'avais
moins de crainte à fumer marc gervais
découvre qu'à saint jérôme l'adoption
d'un règlement municipal lui enlève
toute la liberté consentis par la loi
fédérale en plus le propriétaire de son
appartement a récemment modifié son bail
interdiction de fumer de la marijuana
dans toutes les parties privatives et
comme une maison mon bâton c'est pas
dans les recoins de chez nous je peux
pas non plus mais regard peut pas non
plus se retrouve dans l'impossibilité
totale de fumer les gens ne veulent pas
voir des gens fumer du cannabis ne les
bus publics que ça soit du trottoir
l'ispa des grands impacts de
rassemblement le maire de saint-girons
dit avoir simplement respecter l'opinion
de la très grande majorité des jéromis
donc la position qu on oublie une
position de père de famille de mon père
de famille parce que les strictes
oui parce qu'elle est trop non plus ma
peau c'est la bonne décision à prendre
au moment où on se parle comme pour
l'alcool
les villes ont le pouvoir légal
d'encadrer la consommation de cannabis
marc gervais a donc juste trouver un
plan b consommé dans sa voiture une
situation idéale
non c'est loin d'être idéales
et les options mais légalement je
pourrais pas dire si c'est une bonne
chose
le plus important c'est qu'ils ne soient
pas assis derrière le volant m roxane
hamelin est avocate criminaliste le code
criminel prévoit que lorsque vous
occuper la place normalement occupé par
le conducteur dont vous êtes assis
derrière le volant
il ya une présomption que vous assumez
la garde un contrôle si en plus les
véhicules et moteurs ne fonctionnent pas
la personne n'est pas lié à sa
disposition
et ça va dit selon la poursuite de
démontrer que cette personne là assurent
la garde et le contrôle du véhicule
savait très bien qu'en adoptant cette
réglementation fort serait justement le
débo d'arriver à des lieux eu lieu bien
organisée
recommandé par un service de sécurité
publique bien encadrer la façon pour
vraiment la plus intelligente de le
faire c'est des cafés cannabis
faut que le système ça juste pour
permettre à ses agents responsable de
consommer tout simplement
[Musique]